A new actor is taking the blade, but some
people are still thinking of the guy who started
it all.
Marvel Studios announced that Mahershala Ali
will lead a reboot of Blade, starring as the
vampire-hunter and skilled swordsman Eric
Brooks, a half-vampire who, in the comics,
is on a quest to avenge his mother's death.
People went wild at the announcement.
An Academy Award-winning actor breathing new
life into the Blade property?
Sounds killer!
But wait, what about the man Ali is taking
over for in the Blade reboot?
"What's so funny, bright eyes?"
"I'm expecting company!"
Now that Ali is firmly aboard the in-development
movie, it appears that original Blade actor
Wesley Snipes is sunsetting his iconic role
for good.
However, Snipes' fans are holding out hope
that Marvel can make room for him in the Blade
reboot — or else there might be hell to
pay.
Taking to Twitter, one fan suggested that
Marvel should tap Snipes for the role of Abraham
Whistler – Blade's mentor and weaponsmith
whom Kris Kristofferson portrayed in the original
Blade trilogy — as a way to honor the actor.
They tweeted:
"Let's start the movement right here, right
now, for @MarvelStudios to cast @wesleysnipes
as Whistler in the reboot of #BladeMCU.
The entire current run of comic-book movies
owes everything to the 1st Blade movie, so
a little honouring of the legacy he left isn't
too much to ask."
Another said that no matter how great Ali
is in the role, Snipes will forever be the
actor associated with Blade.
They tweeted:
"Wesley Snipes still is the baddest Blade
we'll ever see in this lifetime.
Even though the role has been given to [Mahershala
Ali] in a reboot, special respect to this
man!!!"
Elsewhere, fans said that the Blade reboot,
quote, "won't go over well" without Snipes
involved, that Snipes, quote, "deserves" a
cameo or a supporting role in the movie, and
that Marvel can go ahead and cancel the film
ahead of time because they don't want it if
Snipes isn't starring.
User @DavidWDougan argued:
"I think a #Blade reboot is long overdue,
but Mahershala Ali has his work cut out if
he wants to be cooler as the character than
Wesley Snipes was."
Meanwhile, @DakotaMiller said:
"I'm the biggest Blade fan ever & super stoked
about Marvel announcing the reboot, but if
Wesley Snipes isn't at least in a cameo I'm
gonna riot."
On the flip side, Twitter user @Guavah_Go
wrote that Blade fans should be more open-minded
about Ali's casting, stop focusing so much
on the past, and have faith in how Ali will
approach the new iteration of the character.
Their tweet reads:
"We can appreciate Wesley Snipes as Blade
and also be excited for the reboot.
You CAN have both.
Wesley Snipes was excellent as #Blade.
Ali won't be playing that same version, obviously,
hopefully he brings his own style & dynamic
to the role."
These reactions to Ali's casting as Blade
in the upcoming reboot movie may seem dramatic,
but they're not at all surprising.
Snipes has long made it clear that he's ready
to return to the role he originated with 1998's
Blade, a film that changed superhero movies
forever.
In December of 2018, the 56-year-old actor
took to Twitter to affirm that his teeth are,
quote, "still sharp" for a Blade reboot, and
that it's simply up to Marvel if they'd like
to bring him back on board.
A few months later, Snipes sat down with Vice
and opened up about the possibility of a fourth
Blade movie to follow after Blade: Trinity,
saying
"There are a lot of conversations going around
right now and we're very blessed to have the
enthusiasm and interest in something coming
from that world again.
All the main execs [at Marvel] and my team,
we've been discussing for the past two years.
Everyone's enthusiastic about it, everybody
gets it.
But they got a business to run and they gotta
square the things that they gotta figure out
before they can get to it, I guess."
Fast forward to summer 2019, and it was reported
that Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige
was "fighting" for a new Blade movie — with
Snipes attached in the lead role.
So, what happened?
Well, Mahershala Ali happened.
The Green Book and Moonlight actor rang up
Marvel Studios and essentially pitched himself
as the new Blade, and there was no denying
the powerhouse talent his wish.
As Feige put it:
"When Mahershala calls, you answer."
“That must've hurt."
There's no telling whether the studio will
be receptive if Snipes says point-blank that
he wants a part in the Blade reboot, but considering
that the star essentially paved the way for
all superhero actors who came after him and
that his fans are gunning hard for him to
join the new movie, Marvel would be smart
to not screen his call.
"Some m-----------s are always tryin to ice skate uphill."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.